i woke up to those reports you know a
lot of people
reaching out to me um but it's it's not
true
you know i'll start off off the rip and
say it's not true i said the last time i
spoke to you guys that
a lot of things are being said and you
know it hasn't come for me
so uh number one is not true
um and secondly i'll also say that i i
haven't made any firm decision on
you know what my future will be so
uh there's really no need for anybody
else to
to speak for me or report this or report
that you know for something to be said
as i said the last time i'll i'll speak
directly with
with my team and with neil so
you know that's that what can you share
the conversations you've had with
chauncey since he's been hired and with
neil this off season about how the
organization as a whole
needs to take a step forward so that you
guys
make that next step to a championship
run
i think the the best way to put it is
just to be more urgent
be more urgent about what what our next
step is and how we move forward
you know i think we uh we take we have a
lot of
pride about you know we've made the
playoffs all these years in a row
you know we're not a bad team we're
we're a winning team you know we
we're in the playoffs every year we've
got a great environment we
we in a great city you know we have
great fans
it's a lot of positives you know but i
just think we've we've reached that
point where it's like okay but
it's not enough do we actually want to
win it all
do you know is that what we're shooting
for um
and we got to do things to to show that
you know we got to
you know put action behind that that
desire to to win
at that level and you know that's that's
been my only
thing this entire time but to be clear
and trying to get some clarity on it do
you expect to be an important uniform
this season